welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and the fantastic four has just lost a
more than fantastic spider-man trilogy
director as john watts has announced his
amicable departure from marvel studios's
first stab at marvel's first family
however since the internet is the
internet as soon as the vacancy for the
spot of fantastic four director was
posted on craigslist everybody has been
putting suggestions in with who they
think should helm the much anticipated
film with fan cast fan favorite john
krasinski being one of the most popular
names nerds have been screaming with
their whole chests so let's talk about
this and the secret plans marvel studios
may have hidden for the fantastic four
within the project's very logo because
why not i'm feeling pretty fantastic my
nerd babies i'm feeling pretty fantastic
today but you know what's even more
fantastic our latest obsession shirt
pick it up now the design is amazing new
rockstarsmerch.com and this video is
sponsored by curiositystream more about
them later alright so john watts said
that he pretty much just needed a break
from just doing superhero movies and
after doing a whole trilogy of
spider-man one of the most high stress
jobs you can have which is you know
partly why john watts even left the
fantastic four to begin with it's just
you know you're over it this job is
better suited for people with more
passion for the project people like
ant-man one and two director peyton reed
who has historically had a massive
passion for fantastic four and was
actually developing a fantastic four
movie with fox around the years
2002-2003 before they actually ended up
developing 2005's fantastic four film
with peyton reed's original vision for
the film being that of a fantastic four
set in the 1960s which is something that
a lot of people want and it had more of
your friendly neighborhood vibe than
that of a huge team of like all right we
gotta stop the apocalypse type of
scenarios with peyton reed even
comparing his script to that of the
beatles film a hard day's night that was
a fictional adaptation of the daily
lives of the beatles with reed kind of
wanting to tell the tales of this
celebrity superhuman family being just
super human and relatable and funny
because writing funny movies about
relatable people was what peyton reed
was really good at and he is still good
at to this day because ant-man 1 and 2
are some of my favorite marvel films but
regardless of who may end up directing
the movie my vote is for jordan peele by
the way because he would freaking kill
it my white father kevin feige is very
much in charge of the show and as such
knows the narrative path that he wants
the fantastic four and he's known the
path for a very long time and has
started to plant the seeds within this
very mcu that very much herald the
fantastic fours coming like for example
i believe that the realm of taulo is
likely to be the mcu version of the
planet top the original home planet of
galactus before he got all big and
galactusy and you know gained a few
extra pounds but don't tell myself that
or else it's gonna kick my ass but hey
no judgment a theory that i actually
brought up in a video i made for the
channel a few months back however
speaking of the universe's two-eyed
two-horned giant purple planet-eater
galactus let's take a look at the only
real official piece of mcu fantastic
four information that we have through
the project's logo that was revealed
during its official announcement because
like my homies from cybertron i believe
that the design of this logo carries
more meaning than meets the eye
curiosity stream is the entertainment
brand for people who just want to know
more it's smart tv for your smart tv
curiosity stream showcases true
storytelling for when you want to know
more they've got great documentaries on
every topic about our world and beyond
moon knight got you curious about
ancient egypt check out the tombs of
egypt i'm a big fan of the myths and
monsters series on curiosity street the
first episode really digs into joseph
campbell and his huge impact on modern
storytelling including george lucas and
the star wars films and curiosity stream
has thousands of award-winning
exclusives and originals on topics like
nature science food and more and they've
got 35 collections of expert curated
programs that you can stream on any
device for viewing anytime anywhere it's
netflix for nerds the hulu for history
buffs the disney plus for the scientists
in all of us the hbo max for
for the for the
homies so do yourself a favor and sign
up for curiosity stream and you'll pick
up some better fodder for conversation
than just the weather use code new
rockstars to sign up for just 14.99 for
the entire year so head on over to
curiositystream today and check out what
they got because they got some pretty
great stuff and thanks again to
curiositystream for sponsoring this
video because my nerd babies if you can
only see a blue four in front of a blue
circle i beg you no i implore you to
look a little closer like physically get
closer to your screen touch your eyeball
to the screen but no seriously i don't
think that this is just a blue circle at
all because check out the edges of this
circle this logo is shining almost like
a solar eclipse or like a black hole of
sorts well in my opinion it looks too
suspiciously close to one of the only
things in the universe that galactus the
enemy of the fantastic four fears a
little something called the black sun
making its debut on the pages of rom
number 27 the black sun was revealed to
be one of the few celestial bodies in
all of the universe that galactus could
not eat mostly because the black sun was
a meal that could bite back and bite
back hard because this wasn't your
ordinary sun no located within marvel's
dark nebula it was actually the main
source of super dark magical power for
the dire wraith race of ugly looking
mother who lived on get this wraith
world i don't know who's in charge of
marketing but you really nailed it bud
the dark nebula's soul planet and fun
fact the dire wraiths they're actually
skrulls who got turned super ugly by the
use of the black sun's dark magical
influence and this was like years and
years ago at the beginning of like the
skrulls developments as a society and
rom the space knight actually ends up
tricking galactus into consuming this
black sun instead of his own planet of
galador and galactus is all like oh well
gee thank you thank you so much rom a
yummy star of darkness just gonna get my
eating bib on and oh my god i'm being
eaten alive by giant dark demons the
black sun made in self-defense i've made
a terrible mistake which led galactus to
run from the black sun claiming for the
first time in existence it can be said
of galactus that he has met a world an
entire sector of space which he had not
the stomach to consume and while marvel
studios may not have the rights to roam
space night which is a huge bummer
because i've been dying to see a space
night in the mcu the black sun itself
should very much be within marvel
studios purview as it is part of their
actual universe and not a main character
in the rom mythos so this all being said
with galactus being an impossible to
beat cosmic threat to the mcu that
historically cannot be destroyed i can
see a fantastic four team that has
already existed in the past you know
decades before even your captain
marvel's using this huge source of dark
magical energy as a way to prevent earth
from being a high fiber meal for a big
purple man you know sort of like how
thor did in four ragnarok you can't
defeat me
no i know
but he can't
which could actually end up explaining
the fantastic four's disappearance in
the mcu as a trip to a distant dark
nebula might take a very long time to
complete and if you've seen interstellar
you know that you know time kind of gets
weird when you travel in space you kind
of can miss a couple decades but that is
what i think of this whole fantastic
four situation with what we know so far
i mean we know that justin lin just left
the fast and furious franchise you think
justin lin would do a good job i think
peyton reed would do a good job let us
know who you think again i think jordan
peel be great but hey i'm only one man
maybe if enough of us what demanded
jordan peel who knows what would happen
i don't know i'm just saying but thank
you guys so much for watching this video
you can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] but more importantly you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
social media and when you do on youtube
make sure you hit that notification bell
so you can get notifications every time
we upload a video thanks again for
watching this video i love you guys so
much and i'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
you